Em fizema pulmonar, como fortalecer os
pulmões? Imagina comigo, você sobe dois
lances de escada e no fim sente que o ar
some como se o pulmão tivesse encolhido.
Se você tem fizema, eu sei que essa cena
é comum. Hoje eu vou te mostrar passo a
passo como dar potência ao que ainda é
seu, porque mesmo que o fizema não volte
atrás, dá para melhorar o fôlego, a
resistência, a qualidade de vida. Vamos
junto. Primeiro, um segredinho que muda
o jogo. A forma de soltar o ar chama-se
biquinho. Respiração com lábios
semicerrados. Inspira pelo nariz por 2
segundos, faz um biquinho e solta
devagar
por 4 a 6 segundos, como se apagasse uma
vela sem pressa. Isso cria uma
pressãozinha que mantém os bronquíolos
abertos por mais tempo, ajuda o ar preso
a sair e reduz a falta de ar. Parece
bobo, mas funciona. Treine 5 minutinhos,
três a cinco vezes ao dia e useço,
subindo rampa, tomando banho, trocando
de roupa. Agora vamos acordar o cinto do
pulmão. Diafragma.
Deite ou sente-se confortavelmente. Uma
mão no peito e outra na barriga. Inspira
pelo nariz, fazendo a barriga subir.
Solta no biquinho,
deixando a barriga descer. Evite de
levantar o ombro. É a tal respiração
diafragmática. Faça séries de 10
inspirações com pausas. No começo dá
trabalho, mas o corpo aprende. É tipo
treinar marcha lenta antes de correr.
Quer dar um passo extra? Treino dos
músculos inspiratórios com dispositivos
de resistência. Aqueles aparelhos que
você puxa contra uma molinha. Eles
aumentam a força dos músculos da
respiração e podem reduzir a sensação de
cansaço. Regra prática, 5 a 7 dias por
semana, 30 a 60 respirações por sessão.
Começa leve, vai progredindo. É a
musculação do fôlego sem pressa e sem
heróis. Doutor, e o exercício? Eu fico
sem ar, justamente por isso. Pulmão
gosta de movimento, mas com estratégia.
A receita que funciona, caminhar ou
pedalar 20 a 40 minutos, três a 5 dias
por semana, usando o biquinho nas
subidas. Mantém uma conversa curta
enquanto caminha. Se não consegue falar,
reduza. Duas vezes por semana. Faça
força de forma segura, sentar e levantar
da cadeira, empurrar elástico, levantar
garrafinhas. Uma a duas séries de 8 a 12
repetições para pernas, costas, peito e
braços. Mais músculo é igual a menos
falta de ar, porque o corpo fica
eficiente, pede menos oxigênio por
tarefa. Aquecer 5 minutos, esfriar 5
minutos, sem drama, a consistência é que
manda. Outra sacada que muita gente
subestima, postura e posições de alívio.
Sentar um pouco inclinado pra frente,
cotovelos apoiados nas coxas, soltar o
ar no biquinho. Isso destrava o peito na
crise de falta de ar. Em pé, incline
levemente o tronco e apoie as mãos numa
bancada. Use como pit stop quando o
fôlego encurtar. Casa e ar puro. Se der,
cuide da qualidade do arde você vive.
Poeira, fumaça, dor forte e mofo
inflamam as vias aéreas. Vente ele à
casa, evite produtos com cheiro intenso
e se cober no orçamento, um purificador
com filtro EPA no quarto ou onde você
passa mais tempo pode ajudar,
principalmente em dias de poluição ou
fumaça de queimadas e hidratação
simples. Água ao longo do dia mantenha
as secreções menos pegajosas. A
alimentação do pulmão também existe,
viu? Quem tem enfisema perde massa
muscular com mais facilidade. Então
pense em proteína de qualidade
distribuída ao longo do dia. Ovos,
peixes, frango, leguminosas, legumes
coloridos, azeite e castanhas. Antes do
exercício, refeições leves ajudam. A
barriga pesada roubo o ar. Então, 3 pode
ser útil pra massa muscular em alguns
casos. Fale sempre com seu médico ou
nutricionista, porque cada corpo conta
uma história. Suplemento que merece
conversa franca com seu médico é a
cetilciste,
em quem tem muito muco e exacerbações
frequentes, pode reduzir as crises ao
longo do tempo. Não é bala de prata, não
substitui básico, mas pode ser uma peça
do quebra-cabeças. A dose, indicação são
médicas. Primeiro vem a segurança.
Falando no básico, que salva, mantenha
sua vitamina C.
zinco e ded de dado em níveis adequados.
Isso reduz infecções que derrubam o
pulmão. Experimente usar o própolis com
acompanhamento médico. Inaladores usados
do jeito certo fazem enorme diferença.
Peça revisão de técnica em toda a
consulta. E claro, se você ainda fuma,
parar a intervenção mais poderosa. Mesmo
com anos de estrada, o risco de piora
cai, a tosse melhora e o fôlego
agradece. E não é na marra. Use adesivo,
goma, remédios como bupropriona,
vareniclina,
terapia psicológica. Escolha suas armas
com ajuda profissional. Tem também o
lado mente e corpo. Asiedade aperta a
respiração. A respiração apertada
alimenta a ansiedade e isso vira um loop
enganado. Então, técnicas de ritmo,
inspirar três, soltar seis, música,
canto em grupo, meditação guiada,
alongamentos, oração, tudo isso ajuda a
destravar o tórax. Muita gente acha
brega, mas experimentar por 10 a 15
minutos por dia pode surpreender. E
quando ajuda, se a falta de ar piora, de
repente, se os lábios ficam roxos, se
você tem febre, catarro que muda de cor,
fica esverdeado ou aumenta muito, é hora
de avaliação rápida. Pra rotina, o combo
que mais dá resultado é parar de fumar,
se for o caso, treinar respiração,
exercitar o corpo, alimentar-se bem,
revisar remédios e fazer reabilitação
pulmonar com equipe habilitada. A
fisioterapia respiratória é ouro. Pense
nisso como manutenção preventiva do seu
motor. Deixa eu fechar com uma história
real de consultório.
O seu João, 68 anos, em Fisema moderado,
dizia: "Doutor, a minha rua tem uma
ladeira que me humilha". A gente montou
um plano, biquinho na subida, treino de
pernas, 25 minutos de caminhada,
elástico duas vezes por semana, NAC,
discutido com um colega pneumologista,
reposição sensata de vitamina C, D e
zinco, própolis purificador no quarto e
foco no café da manhã com proteína. Em
outras semanas ele não virou atleta, mas
a ladeira virou gente boa. Ele parava no
meio, fazia o biquinho, retomava o
fôlego e a vida recomeçou a caber no
peito. Isso que eu quero para você.
Respira comigo devagar. Puxa
dois pelo nariz.
Solta seis.
Repete pouco a pouco, um jeitinho e
ciência. Seu pulmão pode não ficar novo,
mas pode ficar muito mais eficiente. E
eficiência no dia a dia é liberdade.